[Music]
bingo
oh my gosh just saying he burnt the
shutter walk
away from center law he steals the
hatred
esports have always been about skill
training your mind and body to produce
incredible results showing off true
mastery
leaving nothing to change
but in hearthstone leaving things to
chance forms the very foundation
of the game you know once in a while
you're just gonna take a pyroblast back
to your own face
but that's really what this card is
about it's about just creating
crazy moments you never know where your
choices might take you
and the possibilities can be
exhilarating in the words of the late
great tj sanders
punished but where's the line between
taking the occasional gamble and
needing no skill whatsoever to win games
the hearthstone community had to find
out the hard way
and despite a bumpy ride of hellish
balance
the game managed to survive
all games fit somewhere on the
randomness spectrum some leave very
little to chance while
others are fundamentally built on the
luck of the draw card games specifically
are inherently random
the order of the cards in your deck the
chance you or your opponent have to draw
a specific card and even the order cards
get played in are
unpredictable most of it is governed by
a random number generator or
rng but in hearthstone's case the cards
themselves add an
additional element of surprise and
here's firebat explaining why
that isn't always a good thing so i
understand that they're supposed to be
drawing g in a card game
i also understand that or i believe
anyway
that the design of some of the cards
emphasizes it more than it needs to
over the years hearthstone has seen some
truly insane cards
all broken because of the rng they added
to the game there was yogg saron who
cast a random spell for
every spell you'd cast that game even
after he killed himself
which was eventually removed from the
game after a lot of top players
complained that it was broken
so many animations stand against
darkness
bloodlust charge
oh my god that was
huge piloted shredder summoned a random
two constant minion when it died which
could throw off a player's strategy
entirely for example
here's reynad getting screwed i don't
think there's a way to avoid
losing the shredder here
and i hope he doesn't have the equality
oh my [ __ ] god i hate
this video game dr boom was once
considered a must-have
especially for new players he was
arguably the best legendary card
available and he was banned from
standard in 2016
alongside piloted shredder and to see
one of the
many reasons why dr boom got banned just
watch as kolento gets
super lucky
wow oh my god such rng
the card babbling book infamously
decided the result of a hearthstone 2016
world championship quarterfinals match
between pavel and amnesiac
after two very lucky draws from havel
babbling book got a new nickname
paveling book this could be huge here we
go
oh look at it oh my god the heart break
on the face remember he
pulled it his own hair a little bit
there he was so frustrated and
i don't blame him and then there was
ragnaros
anyway you get the idea while
hearthstone is undeniably a huge
commercial success for blizzard
the randomness inherent to the game made
turning it into an esport a challenge
from the start
sure there are some cards that give you
a little bit of wiggle room when it
comes to managing the randomness but at
the end of the day
it's still a numbers game and here's e
core 100
explaining just how much hearthstone
revolves around managing that randomness
so let's just say i'm the player
randomly generating a ton of stuff right
let's just say my priest
there'll be a lot of cases where you
won't actually randomly generate a ton
of good things
but you have to somehow use the
resources that you got
to get to the end goal of you winning
like we already said in esports
skill is everything so when it came to
hearthstone competition
losing to a random play feels bad
some would say that there's a beauty to
watching the perfectly lucky play go off
or
seeing someone take a huge risk and
watching it work out
unless of course you're the one on the
other end of the rng a bunch of free
controls honestly
um oh never mind
it happened right now hold on no signs
whoever was holding don't walk away
bathe in that man's misery don't try and
back out of it now
now blizzard wants there to be
randomness in hearthstone from their
perspective it's what gives new players
a fighting chance against seasoned pros
my journey into competitive artstone was
just playing for fun at the beginning
for
a year then qualifying randomly to
a tournament and in the last prelims and
winters i qualified did the top four
finish
went to bahamas and in the bahamas did
another top four finish so here i am
going to the world championship but when
it comes to pro play
the general consensus was that
hearthstone was just too random and
don't take my word for it
here's former pro life coach explaining
his frustrations with the game back in
the day
it's not even that important how you
it's like coin flipping with a little
bit of strategy
so maybe how you rotate the coin so that
it
flies through the air in a specific
angle so that you can have a ten percent
higher chance of
having this head outcome or the um
tailor outcome
the rng elements in hearthstone are so
strong that many believe that it's
possible to win games against better
players who just happen to have worse
luck
which would undermine the integrity of
competition if it were true
you play very well extremely well and
you can lose
a lot of games or you play very crappy
and you win a lot of games and even if
it weren't true
that thought adds a lot of doubt to any
result
and anyone interested in playing in the
hearthstone global finals really did
have to win
a lot of games the hearthstone
championship tour a system of gathering
points from a bunch of blizzard
sanctioned events and majors
proved to be problematic because of how
many events there were how convoluted
tabulating points could be
and how geographically spread out the
qualifying players were sometimes
in other games trophies and tournament
wins are the things that define
superstar players but in hearthstone
where a lucky break could be the
difference between winning and losing a
tournament
trophies didn't hold as much weight to
truly be recognized as a great
hearthstone player
you have to play and win so many matches
that people can't chalk up your
victories to rng
and here's solemn explaining how rng can
really mess with competitive results
while it started out as a game that
resolved around decision making
and strategy it now heavily resolves
around random effects
how lucky can you be and how unlucky can
your opponent be more more cards that
were introduced in the recent stats have
an effect that either generate something
randomly or just have a straight up
random effect
it's just random 10 20
swings and win rate that don't need to
exist
so how does anyone find a lasting
success in a game like this
well because of all the reasons we
listed true influence in the hearthstone
scene lies outside of the tournament
space
i think the bullet's in the second
chamber
back in hearthstone's heyday when it was
one of the top five most watched games
on twitch regularly
names like disguise toast and hafu were
huge
but hearthstone has since tumbled down
twitch's ranks
it holds steady in the top 20 but it
isn't the juggernaut it used to be
there are of course still the die-hard
hearthstone devotees who are committed
to streaming their favorite game no
matter what is popular on twitch at the
moment
i started this turn with nothing on the
board and now this is my board
welcome to hearthstone 2020. and part of
the reason for hearthstone's decline is
balance issues something that blizzard
has received plenty of criticism over
the years for
even from top personalities in the scene
like preparing the problem is
that blizzard has made a ridiculous
effort to try to legitimize and make the
hearthstone esports scene as serious as
possible but then
then you have yogg-saron so that that
doesn't make any sense
right you can't have what's supposed to
be what they're trying to
perceive as a super serious esport
while at the same time having
ridiculously rng card you can have
you can have one of those but you can't
have both of those hearthstone's slow
decline is reflected not only in the
diminished twitch views but
also in the lower amount of money you
make for choosing to go pro
and the steady trickle of pros who
choose to retire but
even as many of the game's mainstays
leave the competitive circuit is still
running events
he has twilight drake hog steed hog
steed iron bark schumer
nice most importantly he has loosened
bark and heels
yes indeed it was twice
gonna be going to the world
championships what a win
there are new and exciting storylines
coming out of hearthstone and despite a
shorter 2019 competitive season blizzard
continues to pump out new content to
keep things fresh
in 2019 blizzard replaced hct with a
newer
simpler system called hearthstone
masters arsenal championship tour is
coming to an end i've seen some of the
best hearthstone that's ever been played
happened during http
hearthstone faces some stiff competition
from the likes of legends of runeterra
and magic the gathering arena along with
the rise of auto battlers like dota auto
chess and team fight tactics
but it did have an answer to the last
two in the form of a new game mode
battlegrounds and despite its fair share
of disasters over the last few years
hearthstone's unpredictability is what
keeps it both fresh
and frustrating five years after its
release
never mind i love firestone best car
game in the world
not knowing what comes next can be a
nerve-wracking experience
especially if your career is on the line
but for the spectator
the stakes make all the difference and
for at least some of the pros
the potential highs might just make up
for the lows
[Music]
man i hate that it snowed it's
disgusting and sickening oh
yeah i am a summer person don't you hey
don't you say that like it's a slur
you can't even go outside right now why
not
cold solid cold i don't want to be
cold